simply a new trailer turned up and it
seems to be covering mostly the second
and third episode there are a lot of
shots that are confirming a few major
theories so without further due let's
just jump into it in the shot sources
giving a speech to other lords about the
mad king's daughter and warns them that
she will destroy the realm
Cersei highlights that they must stand
together in order to stop Daenerys and
her conquest over the Seven Kingdoms
as we can see Cersei holds court with
randyll Tarly and his son taken which is
confirming a theory that I introduced
you with a few days ago basically that
video I said that Cersei has enemies all
around her she's basically surrounded
and violet seems like the Mad Queen's
reign will not last long we should
reconsider that as she will make a few
alliances of the great importance
Cersei needs more allies and most
importantly searching in sanella that
would ensure the provision of a foe to
the capital which is of the great
importance in a time of war long story
short in that video I showed you red
refuse from hints from the season
premiere regarding sources new allies
that would provide her both an army and
the provision of a food to the capital
and this trailer confirmed it Cersei
will make an alliance with powerful
vessel house of house Tyrell to
overthrow lady Elena
upon that same vessel House will become
the great house and will rule over the
rich therefore Cersei will ensure the
provision of a fall to the capital which
is of the great importance at the time
of war even though it will not last long
for his betrayal over land Tyrell
randyll will most probably be awarded to
the place in a small council and it's
all says it assumed that he would be
appointed as the new lord paramount of
the rich and warden of the south this
trailer confirmed that once they make an
alliance
Jaime Lannister leading Lannister army
along with Randall and Deakin Tarly
leading their Tarly army will march on
Highgarden the seat of house Tyrell
which will result with their victory if
you would like to know more details
about this confirmed theory which
besides the fall of Highgarden
also includes the death of Lady Olenna
Tyrell feel free to check out my
recently published video by the name of
Lana's death in season 7 as I've already
said in that video I backed up every
single prediction of mine with a scene
from the season premiere as well as from
the previous seasons that decide for
sharing this alliance also for share of
their march on Highgarden however there
are also few shots of your own rager
arriving at King's Landing and parading
with his prisoners through its streets
all the way to the red
keep to once again propose an alliance
accompanied with a marriage to Cersei to
pledge his army and his own fleet to her
cause but this time Cersei will not
refuse those shots are confirming that
your creature is going to successfully
defeat er in the sand snakes in the
fleet battle which should take place in
the upcoming second episode whereupon he
will come to King's Landing and bring
his gift of Cersei Lannister which
should Azure on set himself prove his
honest intentions leading to an alliance
accompanied with a marriage deal between
those two villains I don't expect you to
trust me outright you need proof of my
honest intentions in my experience the
surest way to open his heart is with a
gift a priceless gift I won't return to
King's Landing until I have that for you
Euron will bring captured yara Greyjoy
hilarious Sen and her daughter tie into
the Capitol as a gift for Cersei and
even though urines initial plan of
sailing to slavers Bay to bring the
nares back to Westeros as his wife and
conquer the Seven Kingdoms with their
combined forces failed urine will still
marry a queen while conquering the Seven
Kingdoms is highly questionable while
the fate of urines prisoners remains
unknown taking into account the tiara
Larry and trainer searched his enemies
especially the sand snakes who back in
the season 5 finale killed search his
daughter it is it assumed that they will
either commit suicide with a poison or
will be tortured and eventually killed
in the hands of the met Queen the fact
that Iran is going to defeat Yara in the
sand snakes in a fleet battle isn't
surprising at all since you're in
Greyjoy is widely unpredictable a
cunning strategist and the warrior that
possesses proven military tactics kills
urine has spent the last few years as a
pirate breathing from Alton to Cardiff
and is known as the most feared pirate
alive throughout the history urine
carried out one of the opening attacks
of the Greyjoy rebellion which happened
approximately nine years before the
beginning of Game of Thrones series
urine carried out attack in which he
destroyed the Lannister fleet at
Lannisport which was mentioned two times
throughout the series this was mentioned
by Tyrion Lannister in the very first
season of the series as in the fourth
episode Tyrion told to Theon about his
memories of witnessing the raid on
Lannisport caused by Theon's uncle euron
greyjoy
the second time it was mentioned by
Jaime Lannister in the season 7 premiere
urine has the iron fleet which he claims
is the greatest Armada Westeros has ever
seen which accompanied with him being an
experienced and proven captain
strategist and a warrior makes his
upcoming victories not that surprising
before I focus on another shot let me
also provide an answer on a very common
question regarding urine and his diary
fleet which is how did your own great
German is to build a thousand ships in
the previous season you recommended to
everyone to chop down every tree they
find to build him thousand ships in
order to conquer Westeros but the Iron
Islands are small and rocky with poor
soil and hardly any natural resources
meaning that it certainly didn't have
enough trees for the Ironborn to build
him the greatest Armada Westeros has
ever seen you don't care about the
they're nothing but rocks and bird [ __ ]
and a lot of very unattractive people
the iron fleet on the other hand had
something else entirely
it's the greatest mother Westeros has
ever seen however in the season premiere
Jimmy might have provided us an answer
on that question as there's a scene in
which she said that the only thing the
Ironborn know how to do is steal things
they can't build or grow themselves
which should be an answer on your
question I'm no good at anything I know
the on do the better angry little people
I know how to do steal things they can't
build a grow themselves in the
description for the second episode there
stated that the nearest receives an
unexpected visitor and violin my
previous videos I said that an
unexpected visitor is most likely
Melisandre as we got to see her in
Dragonstone in the first official
trailer of the seventh season this
trailer confirmed it beside the shot in
which she means Daenerys there's also a
shot of where is joining Melisandre on
Dragonstone the shot in which the red
priestess means Dany is also accompanied
with Melisandre speech Melisandre says I
believe you have a role to play as does
another let's continue with a few shots
of someone who I believe is Jon Snow
arriving at Dragonstone beside a fact
that Jon will receive Sam's letter in
which he states that there's plenty of
dragonglass on Dragonstone island Jon
will also receive an invitation from the
mother of dragons to come and meet her
all genres the Lord of Runestone and the
powerful bannermen of how serene states
that the Targaryen cannot be trusted
Jon states that they can't hope to
defeat the night Kings army on their own
and highlights that Daenerys has dragon
fire the king in the north will in the
following episode go to Dragonstone to
meet Daenerys in order to try to
persuade her into sending her armies and
dragons north and in order to collect
his magic unless he can beside those
shots of another huge meeting we also
have a few more shots from interval
including this one in which we can see
children including a girl being taught
how to handle a bow and arrow this
trailer also provide us a few shots of
little finger teaching sense another
lesson about manipulation Baelish says
everyone is your enemy everyone is your
friend every possible series of events
is happening all at once
Petyr Baelish might be cunning and
ruthless manipulator but it's
that census sees through his game it
seems that Sansa has learned a great
deal from Littlefinger and Cersei
throughout the years which might lead to
Littlefinger's downfall there are also
few shots of Jorah Daenerys dragons and
Dragonstone as well as a few shots of
the unsullied attacking Casterly Rock
which should take place in the third
episode I already made a video regarding
Daenerys conquest or the Lannister
stronghold in which I provided you every
detail about how exactly will the
unsullied manage to conquer one of the
most formidable and well defended
castles sinaloa Westeros so feel free to
check it out other than his trailer HBO
has recently released official images
from the second episode there's a folder
in which the nares gathers her allies
and advisors in the chamber of the
painted table at Dragonstone long story
short the nurse will have a huge meeting
regarding her conquest of the Seven
Kingdoms then we have a photo that
includes Sam still performing his Mineo
duties in the Citadel in presence of an
arch maestra Bros in the upcoming
episode Sam you'll almost certainly
fight out a cure for juris disease with
the help of an arch maester while
there's also a high possibility that the
Cure they're looking for is dragonglass
if you didn't watch my previous video
let me just say that the season 7
premiere gave us a few hints that
dragonglass decided being capable of
killing and creating White Walkers as
well as being capable of saying man from
dying and turning into white might also
be capable of curing greyscale however
we also got to see the king in the north
and our c-word preparing to leave
Winterfell for Dragonstone about which I
talked earlier in this video
but before Jon leaves he will have an
interesting conversation with
Littlefinger in the crypts which will
not end well for Petyr Baelish official
photos also include the Starks sisters
and while census at Winterfell
Arya still heading south this photo has
revealed arias next stop on her journey
to the capital which is Dean at the
crossroads